بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد كتالحين
باي الحافظ ظ المحدث الفقيه ابو زكريا
يحيى ابن شرف النووي رحمه الله تعالى رحمه
واسعه
[Silence]
almost 80
‏in with the chapters
and
weve taken about 20 narrations through
on
roughly
100 narrations
from
and about a dozen or so dozenes
individual verses from the quر
‏That's a lot of knowledge. That is a
lot of information
and it's not to be taken for grant not
so
for جزاكم الله. يقول باب اليقين والتوكل
اليقين
والتوكل
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى both
and
heart are
largely but they have they have effects
on person behavi person spe person
both of these
‏forlimy
to have minimum of
and so speak about each of these
acts of worship ان شاء الله تعالى
separately first of all
‏is certainty
that is so strong
no
can
debase it no can shake it this is what
is referred to as certainty this is
called
in the arabic langage of
ر
الله سبحانه وتعالى
اليقين
واعبد ربك حتى
ياتيك اليقين اليقين هنا بمعنى الموت
باجماع المفسرين
اللهقين
[Silence]
‏Why? Because
certain is
the inevitable
and that is that all human being
all agree no matter where we come from
what we believe no matter what we all
agree that death is going to come for
each and every one of usentually
we ‏can try to squirm we can try to
wiggle away but it's going to snatch us
up from our warm warm bedsentually
no matter what we do and so the Arabs
would refer to death asق
right
they used to refer to it asقي
because it is something that is
absolutely certain and everyone has
agreed
‏and
point here
is
certainty
and that is that a person
in what has said in what the propet
has said
with such certainty
that they
‏as inevitable as
inevitable as parad andell reward and
punishment
things are
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران من سوره البقره
يقين
سبحانه وتعالى هدى للمتقين
الذين يؤمنون بالغيب ويقيمون الصلاه ومما
رزقناهم ينفقون
والذين يؤمنون بما انزل اليك وما انزل من
قبلك وبالاخره هم يوقنون
الله
تقوى
as
people
are absolutely
of the here of the resurrection of
anything that occurs after
the word here after
رخره
[Silence]
‏And so
when
this certainty
this is a great
and the more of this certainty person
has the high their stature with Allah
we look at
this certainty here certainty of the
here certainty of resurrection
‏is
ch it's not something happ to you a ch
you make you make the chice to be
that what your messenger has said to you
will come to pass
and if you make that chice that
certainty will
‏andar
and that will save you from the of
the days when it is you are vulnerable
and this is whyers
to the vulnerable
of the human
‏is go
are the areulable
[Arabic recitation]
جمعهم ربنا سبحانه وتعالى الثلاثه مع بعض
الموت
ها
الله سبحانه وتعالى
فتنه ابو
الله
يحيى
يا يحيى خذ الكتاب بقوه
واتيناه
الحكم صبيا
وحنانا من لدنا وزكاه وكان تقيا
وبرا بوالديه ديه ولم يكن جبارا عصيا
والسلام عليه
يوم ولد
ويوم يموت ويوم يبعث حيا
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏need
[Silence]
عيهان
وسلام علي يوم ولدت ويوم اموت ويوم ابعث
حيا ذلك عيسى ابن مريم
الله سبحانه وتعالى عيسى دعا
سلام
[Silence]
and those days
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏Why is that grouped in there?
Imagine each of us was each of us born
into perfect circumstances
perfect.
Perfectly safe, perfectly believing,
perfectly nurturing circumstances.
‏Many of us may come from very terrible
backgrounds may very environ
in spite of the bad influences in spite
of theangers in spite of we were we able
to be in we able to make it someh to the
we able to worship الله سبحانه وتالى
‏that
a godly
protection from الله سبحانه وى that's
the only the way that we able to make it
far without the complely ravaging
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يعلمنا ما
ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا وان يزيدنا
علما ويقينا وتوكلا وتقى والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
[Silence]
خليك خليك
كده